and thank you very much for the
invitation I'm really happy to be here
so the talk is mostly about repeated
games and how people learn in the
specific context of transportation
networks but I thought what I would
start to do first is a kind of how did
we get there type of recap because the
transportation network evolved radically
over the last 10 years so if you think
about the traditional approach to
instrumenting the environment in which
the state duties would deploy sensors
whether they were static whether they're
hard wired or Wireless in a sense this
is the way public agencies have been
thinking about it for the last probably
half century and of course if you look
historically at the rise of the mobile
internet and you know you might
recognize on this chart devices that are
pretty much vintage like the Commodore
64 or other things that you might have
used to play video games back in the 80s
the smartphone the rise of this my
smartphone has completely radically
changed transportation in a quite an
unexpected way in the sense that it was
not designed for it so first I'm gonna
talk a little bit about mobile
millennium which was the project that
started all this back in 2008 in the
context of how the smartphone evolved in
its ecosystem and its capabilities so
you can see this is the right around the
time when the iPhone was launched the
first iPhone did not have a GPS and
where it led and where we are today this
is the outline of the talk a little bit
about the historical perspective then
I'm gonna go into the core of the new
mathematical model that we're trying to
put together to model how companies that
route people in the transportation
network in a sense might be modeled and
then talk a little about heterogeneous
games and what that means for congestion
so mobile millennium was the first
traffic app ever launched in North
America to gather probe information from
GPS enable smart phones running on
Symbian and rim this was one of the
phones it was running at the time it
looks like a vintage object good for a
museum now the first launch was actually
from the Brooklyn campus we had 5,000
downloads and very quickly which was
huge at the time which of course now is
ridiculously small
and very quickly was bootstrapped by a
lot of other feeds that the company of
the time Nokia was gathering of course
Nokia was the giant cell phone provider
at the time and so that enabled us to
you know transition from this which
unfortunately is still alive but in this
form but which was a traffic information
website back in the 2008 to this which
was probably in California the first
ever traffic information system that was
powered mostly by mobile data and of
course now all of you have this on your
phone it's something that is very
classic but we had a lot of fun building
the first prototype and I'll just tell
you about this in three slides you know
working with some of the agencies that
are in the field at the time was
challenging in the sense that they
wanted proof that probe data could be
enough to feed a traffic information
system which now has become a reality so
back in 2008 we rented a hundred cars
and asked two hundred students to
participate to a gigantic field
experiment where they would be driving
back and forth on ten miles a freeway in
the hope of creating a situation in
which the penetration of vehicles
equipped with these devices would be
around two percent which was the
18-month forecast of what penetration
rate would be at the time so Nokia
wanted to know whether 18 months from
that time they would be able to run a
system with roughly that penetration of
phones now the penetration of phones is
probably over a hundred percent because
people have multiple devices in their
cars and cars are connected and so but
then of course there was a different
story and so this is what the experiment
looked like back in the days and in
order to corroborate everything we're
gathering we also had dispatched crews
of students with video cameras on the
bridges to film everything so we would
have access to travel time of all the
vehicles on the freeway this is the
depiction of what the 100 vehicles were
at the time each of the dot was one of
the vehicle carrying a phone we were
holding a press conference with a deputy
director of Caltrans and the CTO of
Nokia back then and displaying to the
press in real time what probably was the
first time ever in history that you had
a live display 100% fed by mobile data
so there was no static data at the time
that was broadcasting traffic
information in
and the experiment lasted for ten hours
there was a major accident in the middle
we ended up catching it right before the
police but there's good because in a
sense for ten minutes people thought the
system was going south everything was
breaking that person who used to work at
traffic calm was calling the traffic
comm headquarters to check on the
accuracy of our information people were
starting to get nervous and my blood
pressure was going up until we found out
that there was an accident because
pagers which is another defunct devices
of all the police that was there started
beeping 10 minutes later and so at that
point we figured out we had capture and
an accident faster than the traffic
information systems at the time and the
rumor sends bodies in the room is that
percolated the accident on purpose to
demonstrate the technology and my
response to this is that the rumor of
course came from Stanford so we built
several generations of that system which
is a fairly common built now the person
who built that is now at Apple traffic
and there's a lot of similarities we can
see in the way we built this and what we
see on Apple maps nowadays so you have
feeds which of course are at zero genius
that are in put into filters models we
heard very nice LWR model that we use a
lot in the previous talk estimation and
forecast and target customers this is
what half a percent of our data was
that's the percent we could show at the
time this is many years now so this is
about 500 taxi vehicles that were
connected using some similar software in
San Francisco red dot is a vehicle black
dot is a GPS track every couple of
seconds you can imagine I mean uber has
thousands of vehicles now in the city
all connected to ways and many other
devices so you can imagine the amount of
data that is available today at the time
if you had plotted that data over the
course of a day this is the granularity
you would have seen it was already quite
high not high enough to reconstruct
flows high enough to reconstruct speed
and travel times of course companies
like Google nowadays through their apps
running on all platforms and through
their own platform Android probably have
near hundred
penetration rate if you accumulate
everything they have so in a sense the
problem has changed from estimation to
or for estimation for very low
penetration to very high penetrations
and so where this story fits is really
you know at to penetration a two percent
penetration rate so that means if two
percent of the vehicles have a device
that sends data that's what you get so
this is a time-space diagram and so
common tool used by traffic engineers so
you have time you have post mile and the
dot represents a GPS track every couple
seconds and then the color indicates the
speed this is for the day of the
experiment you can see the accident in
the morning
congestion picking up not really
recuperating throughout the day and then
even in congestion picking up again and
so the type of work that we did in the
last decade on this was well if you
decimate this data
so here's estimated spatially could you
reconstruct what the traffic was and
again very important ten years ago
nowadays you could argue with the
penetration of GPS maybe it's not that
important anymore but using models just
like the LWR model that was shown by
Balaji in the previous talk this is what
we could reconstruct so if you run
extended Kalman filter or actually in
that case ensemble command filter
because it's nonlinear non smooth on a
discretized LWR PDE
so the the very very hyperbolic system
you saw before you can pretty much
reconstruct the entire flow pattern
really really accurately so we were very
excited and people you know I started
asking us well how do you compare to
Google so we used to for a couple month
be faster than Google so we would this
is an example of what the Google feed
would be every 30 seconds back in 2011
this is what our feed would be and what
you would see what the model says that
when an accident happened you can see
the shockwave grow really fast and it
would take another 15 minutes at that
point to appear on the Google feed
that's because we had faster data and
also much better models with LWR PD of
course this was many years ago there's
an army of people at Google who built a
really phenomenal engine and now they're
their engine is quite nice and so I
think it's fair to say that at this
point if you think of the evolution of
Technology over the years the to the
years of 2008 and 2009 was really the
boom
the action in terms of traffic
estimation like how you take traffic
information how do you make it into a
valuable product and these are the
companies that work with us or hired our
student over the years and in a sense I
think that that field is now very mature
and I think the game is about to change
again because there are companies like
Google who now have the ability to
almost see everybody who is moving on
the freeway so the game of trying to
reconstruct traffic from a very specific
penetration which used to be low to
reconstruct flows maybe it's not so much
relevant anymore when soon there will be
access to every possible vehicle in
multiple ways not just one feed this is
kind of what you see when you see the
rise of the number of users of phones in
the u.s. back in 2010 in Luxembourg you
already had 150 percent penetration that
means 1.5 phone per person and this is
in 2010 so you can imagine with
connected vehicles and and and Ana
mobile internet nowadays in the u.s.
that work also served the state of
California in its procurement and is
very first historical procurement of
data so the type of work we would do for
them then is try to help them evaluate
you know what is good GPS data to buy
what's bad GPS data to buy for example
that feed that we were evaluating always
has a latency of five minutes five
minutes makes GPS almost obsolete if you
want to do real-time traffic management
because you've seen the rapidity at
which traffic jams develop you need to
have it instantaneously or this other
feed you know what's doing high
penetration rates during the evening in
the night because there's a trucking
company again not very helpful if you're
building a live engine to monitor
traffic so these are the type of
criteria that we were trying to build
and so over the last decade the lot of
the work was went into finding the right
mathematical models to integrate that
data to provide at accurate estimates
and finding the penetration rates at
which you would be able to achieve a
certain accuracy and for specific cost
so that's the estimation problem how
from a data like this potentially
decimated you build something like this
and then okay the question is could you
do it for control so in a sense if this
is your traffic patterns
could you be able to reduce congestion
in some specific places remove
congestion in other places and again
using the models that we heard from in
the previous talk the other Brewer
models there was a lot of work over the
last decade in terms of creating optimal
control algorithm to change these
patterns than any pattern you would want
so of course being very patriotic we
chose this pattern but so what this is
is an example of I would say congestion
on demand in which so you have a freeway
again so this is a pretty long freeway
with a bunch of on ramps and off ramps
this is time and this is you know if you
take the LWR equation you like we heard
before you discretize it and you put a
joint bit optimization on top of it
either MPC style or even offline you can
show that provided you have the right
term and you can create pretty much any
patterns you want and so there's a lot
of work still working in ramp metering
right now and this was one of the first
time that we were able to show that you
know we could achieve almost any
arbitrary pattern provided you had a
good calibrated model of the freeway
that got the reviewers mad and it took
us three years I think to get that paper
published but at the end it was
published so one of the work that we've
been working on for a while now together
with many other faculty Peruvian Roberto
and several others was a project in
which now we would like to use this at a
broader scale to manage a corridor and
that means try to find a way to control
all the different assets of the corridor
which in the present case are mostly
traffic lights and metering lights in
order to make the traffic flow better
through the corridor there's a lot of
reasons why you might or might not want
to do this for example the planning
agencies in San Francisco might not want
to decrease the congestion level in the
city because if you decrease congestion
in a sense latent demand will provide
more people to come to the freeway so
there's a lot of debates whether
reducing congestion should be a goal in
itself or whether it should be other
metrics but either way this is a
gigantic optimization program in which
you're trying to assemble all the
different assets you have so local
lights potential routing apps which are
becoming in sense
the next way to manage traffic and
several other things that you can either
instrument or optimally control and that
brings me to the actual core of the talk
which is you know it's 2016 for many
decades we believe that with public
agencies running infrastructure you
could control mobility but the reality
of things is that who controls mobility
today whoever provides you the app you
have on your phone that tells you how to
get there which basically means that
mobility the control of mobility is
switching from something which is
government owned by something which is
private sector owned and which is not
collaborative in nature and that's the
motivation for the work we're doing
right now so if you think of the simple
problem of routing what planners do
nowadays is they have what they call OD
models origin destination models and
they solve something which they call
user equilibrium which is a dynamic
traffic assignment it's in the sense a
Nash equilibrium over resources that
people are competing for which means if
you live here if you work here you're
all competing with everybody else in the
city for the roads and in a sense you're
trying to accomplish what's best for you
which is the shortest path to get there
so you can think of this problem as a
problem in which you have a distribution
of flow and the flow goes from origins
to destinations it can choose different
routes and at every iteration say at the
end of the day or at the end of your
commute you experience a certain latency
so in the past you used to get that
information from the agencies but
nowadays you're getting that information
from your phones and it's unclear what
it does to the system and so it's an
interesting problem to model well from
the kind of extend point it's a you know
repeated decision-making problem but
also it has a lot of practicality so the
way to model it is you know there are
entities who are controlling the flow so
if X percent of you are using Waze
you're gonna follow the Waze routing and
if Y percent use Apple maps you're going
to use the Apple Maps browsing
so there's entities that in a sense
control mobility and these are the
entities that allocate these flows and
at the end of the day whether you did
good
bad you know about it and so you have
your own policy to figure out what
you're going to do the next day and what
you're doing the next day so it's like
you're the way you're routing the flow
at the next day depends on how you did
what you did yesterday and what you
experienced yesterday and so now the
question of doing this optimally for
society is in a sense designing the
right feedback that can achieve that
optimally we're optimally is defined by
you or by you know whoever wants to do
something optimally so this is a repeat
you could view this as a repeated game
and one of the interesting things is you
know how could you design these
allocation schemes in a way that
achieves certain objectives optimally
and people will not be collaborating
there's no reason for company a to share
what they're doing with Company B if
they're competing for that business so
in a sense you only know what you did
you only know what you experienced or if
your company you only know what you told
your users to do and what they
experienced but you don't know what
others did and so you can see how that
can be decentralized and you can plug
different information patterns so this
is a very good metaphor to what happens
on your phone when you type routing
requests in Google it usually gives you
the shortest path that's here to go to
Stanford and it usually gives you near
shortest path like something which is
nearly equivalent ETA and these are the
second or third best choices that Google
typically gives you so what is that that
is usually a shortest path algorithm
running on travel this time distribution
which could be either predictive or just
static depending on the company but it's
not something that results from in
general solving a dynamic user
equilibrium because the data is not
available at global scale so this is
practically selfish routing so this is
instantiation of a realized Nash
equilibrium in which everybody will
choose what is the best for them
so now a lot of companies in that
business these are the typical suspects
that you probably are running all on
your phones and each of them have a
percentage of the market
waise is very popular for example most
of the uber drivers nowadays use ways to
rub themselves that means there's
probably a lot of ways users in the
cities where uber is very present Google
is global so in a lot of places in the
world where there's no other agencies
then that's what people will use so each
of them has a certain percentage of the
market and then each of them will route
their own set of internal users so say 8
of you are using Waze you might not all
get the same route if you go from the
same place to the other same place so
they'll write their flows in a certain
ways which is you know the way they they
choose to run people now in an ideal
world in 10 or 15 years they would
always probably will probably all of
them be solving a dynamic traffic
assignment problem which makes things
globally but nowadays you're getting
your best route which by definition of
what you want is selfish because you
don't want something that is good for
society whether you do you want that too
but ok maybe the first priority is to
get to your destination as fast as
possible and so in a sense what these
are doing is they're all competing for
the same resources and all contributing
to a Nash equilibrium so non cooperative
game in which they're all playing
against each other and so the the model
I'd like to show now is a model of this
phenomena which is what happens in our
routing system and so I'll go back to
the process in a minute but the main
issue with this is first it's not even
clear whether that converges because you
could see see on Monday accompany you
watch everybody on 101 then it's really
bad so you learn so on Tuesday you'll go
on 280 but now everybody's going with
you on 280 so it's bad so once they have
come back to 101 so that process of
iterative learning which is what what in
a sense happening it's not even clear it
converges to anything so the notion of
designing a proper feedback and learning
mechanisms so that they can learn over
time should hopefully lead to at least
some notion of convergence where we can
say well this is converging into
something which hopefully you'll be a
Nash equilibrium and then you could try
to do better
try to do something which is optimal and
so that's kind of the core of the work
here so going yeah
I think you write the book trophy or
enjoy now mostly spice pretty much the
real-time updates on their mouths even
faster yeah well they're the same now
but um because they were acquired by
Google but but bit smitten yeah exactly
yeah and also each company does not know
the other companies learning model I
mean they have different learning rate
some might be more adaptive than others
so understanding the assumptions that
one can make to see where that converges
and how that converges it is still an
open problem and it's going to be an
ongoing problem because each of these
companies what is it what is the
real-time data for example Google is
getting suppose I have an Android phone
and so okay so everybody's providing
their data to so most of the major
company if you have an iPhone Apple
Katsuhiro if you're running a Google app
on an iPhone both Google and Apple or
getting your data and if you're running
an Android
regardless of the app you're running
Google is getting your data that data
provides at best representation of
traffic now and if you have predictive
models for example time distributions
whatever they are Markov chains or
whatever you use you could also see
these as predictive okay that's
different that's that's the traffic
information layer now when you query
Google for
route it queries their system and their
models whatever the models are and it
provides you the shortest path for you
or the fastest path for you because
that's the main product that every is
producing so the work is basically
trying to model what happens when
everybody is using more less the same
product so it's like everybody's getting
the shortest path or the fastest path
from a come from a company regardless of
the model you're using regardless of the
data they're using some crappy company
might have a really poor model poor data
rule phenomenal models phenomenal data
so some get better than others but
everybody is trying to get the shortest
path and that's what it models so this
is there's gonna be tons of questions
because every has is an expert on
traffic and ask questions about it so
I'd like to walk through some of the
talk but I promise you'll be the first
one yeah yeah yeah exactly so every
company has their own little cooking
they buy their ingredients they are they
built they have their own ingredients
which they collect with their own tools
yeah every small s doing the same and at
the end of the day what you are all
doing is you're all querying their
system which provides you the most
selfish thing which is what's best for
you which is your shoulders path and
that's what this models and so um so the
first question is now that everybody's
doing this what does it lead to in terms
of convergence so can you find a class
of feedbacks such that the state of the
system which is the flow allocation
converges to something so that's the
state that's the flow allocation overall
the origins and destinations and we want
this to converge to something we don't
know what that something is and
depending on the assumptions that you
make on the feedback which is the way
people learn you can prove stronger and
stronger convergence to what will end up
being a Nash equilibrium if you make
certain assumptions and that's the
contribution of this work so first what
is a Nash equilibrium so lots of you
have heard it in
ethics of rotting it's an equilibrium of
traffic in which there is no incentive
for you to deviate so Google gets you a
travel time using a path if you deviate
from that your outcome is worse so
there's no reason for you to deviate
that's one way to look at it which you
can characterize in terms of the reward
function and any deviation from the
equilibrium leading to a penalty that
you don't want to incur and there are
links between the Nash equilibrium and
first-order optimality conditions in
optimization which are fairly well known
so first one so I'm gonna go through
three different classes of feedback
which are a ways to model what companies
learn over time and see that the more
assumptions and the stronger the
assumptions the better the convergence
so first one is what's called the no
regret policy in which all you require
is that you you don't have any regret
which means over time if you were
playing the best thing but always the
same then you couldn't do better so
that's called a no regret policy that's
encoded by this here what you can show
is that if you have a no regret policy
then you can guarantee that the average
of this state is converging to a set of
Nash equilibria which by the way might
not be unique and in general will not be
unique because obviously it's very under
determined problem ok so what does that
mean that means that on average so if
you just make that no regret policy so
you assume that your choice is that
these companies make everyday or no
regret then on average the system is
converging to a Nash equilibrium so
that's very interesting from an
optimization perspective but that's very
bad for traffic so it's a very simple
example here which I'm going to
illustrate so we have one origin one
destination another origin and other
destination can go this way and this way
for the red I can go this way this way
or that way for the blue and I'll come
back to what these weights are later
confident convergence on average is
actually bad because in a sense this is
a thing which we can see happening so in
that example you have proportions of
traffic that vary let's the example I
said Monday you do this Tuesday you know
that Wednesday you do this Thursday you
do that so on average it converges on
average but in terms of the traffic is
terrible because basically you have
turbo oscillations of traffic so this is
just a very simple illustration of why
if you make weak assumptions on the
process then you have convergence on
average which is great because in a
sense from an optimization standpoint
that's a gradient descent problem so if
you're just trying to optimize a
function in that case that'd be the
rosenthal potential you can show that
it's a good gradient descent algorithm
you just keep taking the average and
you'll get to the result but from a
modeling perspective and as an analysis
tool for traffic it's bad so it will
converge effectively on average but it
will never converge in terms of the
state and so that shows that you know if
people don't have any rules in the way
they lay or have weak rules in a way
they learn then this could lead to very
bad instabilities so now we make a bit
stronger assumption that's the second
part now say we assume that the learning
phase has a very specific structure and
that structure is called the hedge
algorithm and the hedge algorithm is
essentially saying that your decision at
the next stage with your flow allocation
if your company is proportional to what
it was before multiplied by an
adjustment factor which is proportional
to your reward so it's saying okay well
if you did really bad on this route you
should take it into account and you
should maybe have less flow through this
route but then you adjust it by factor
880 which comes from what's called the
hedge algorithm and you need to make
some assumptions on a 30 so you could
view entity as your learning rate and
you want your learning rate to
ultimately go to zero which means
basically at some point you've more less
converge you're happy with your solution
and that's how you learn over time so
it's a stronger assumption than the
previous one because now you have a
structure to in that learning that is
explicit which actually ends up
resulting from what's called a
replicator equation that equation is the
discretization of the replicator
equation just rewriting it in a certain
case you can add some stochastic noise
to it to add some conversions features
but you can see that now that learning
structure is actually stronger and then
what you can show with this is that now
you have a very stronger convergence to
the Nash equilibria and for that you
need to have some assumptions so in
particular you need some assumptions
that you make on your perturbations you
need some
that you make on you're learning in
particular your learning needs to go to
0 but in Sami needs to diverge and
that's a bit technical but that's
important and then what you can prove
with that is that now you have almost
sure convergence to the set of Nash
equilibria still not unique there's tons
of Nash equilibria but you have
convergence almost surely provided that
you know your learning rate goes to zero
but you have to go to zero not too fast
you still have to be able to divert and
the way to prove that which is a much
stronger result is that so basically the
way you do it is you discretize the OD e
the replicator OD which I saw before and
then you show at every iteration that
you're discritization doesn't diverge
too fast to from your from the
continuous solution and that's these are
continuous and the discrete solutions
and that shows you the convergence so
you can prove it yeah five minutes so
there in the case of routing there is
something called the rosenthal potential
which is a convex function which if you
optimize so basically the cost is the
integral of the link cost we're adding
cost is actually a travel time on each
of the edges if you optimize that
function which is convex then you get
the solution to the Nash equilibria so
there's a complete one on one mapping
between the solution of the Nash
equilibria and the solution to that
convex potential which is what that
function is here and I can explain more
later but but basically in that case
it's it's nice because solving for the
Nash equilibria is a convex program and
that's been known since the 60s so and
that actually is nice because that
brings me to the last model which is
okay now that we have that equivalence
between the Nash equilibria and the
solutions of the rosenthal potential so
f is the rosenthal potential then you
could view this computation of a Nash
equilibrium as solving a convex program
so for this so now the good news about
this is that there's tons of algorithms
that are very efficient at solving
convex programs one of them is mirrored
self which is yet another way to model
the same problem so you could view this
iterative decision process as a step of
emeritus and other
where the mirror decide algorithm is a
classical thing that is after news to
solve convex program so basically at
every step
your iteration now once you have
identified how much cost you incurred in
the previous iteration is minimizing the
sum of these two terms which is
basically your loss
plus some Bregman divergence underrated
weighted by 1 over 8 a T where T is the
same learning rate as in the previous
thing so obviously now this is even more
specific than the previous one because
now you have a very very specific update
rate and you can view this as a way for
your system to learn what happened
before this is the graphical
illustration of what mirror dissenter is
in a sense you're approximating your
convex function by something which is
also convex and with a with a Bregman
divergence and then you can see how
because if you've done any convex
optimization you could decentralize this
so it sounds like doing a way to model
the way different players might not know
what the other players are doing so
bregman divergence design step of Merit
is that can be decentralized and that
would model a game in which players are
decentralized and then you can also
stochastic I say well you don't even
have a really good estimate because say
you're using a really crappy app so you
don't really have a good estimate of how
well you did so the benefit of using
that convex framework is that now you
can generalize that to any kind of
modeling you want and the beauty of this
is that so you can use several
ingredients to finally show that now
you'll have a stronger convergence to
the set of Nash equilibria so you still
need this notion that you know the
learning rates have to not go to zero
too fast but they have to be square
bounded but if you do that now the
benefit is that and for example for this
particular learning rate now not only
proof of convergence to a Nash
equilibria set of Nash equilibria you
still don't know which one but you also
have a speed of convergence the speed of
convergence is both for the value and
also for the state so you can show also
a speed of convergence of the state with
respect to wherever it's converging to
in that speed of convergence is also
written in terms of the brakeman
divergence so you can see every time we
put more assumptions then we have more
guarantees of convergence and so that's
what the that's what we can get with
this model now of course we don't know
what Google's policy is we don't know
what Apple's policy is so the next
question is okay how could we show that
this model is something that can model
reality and obviously we don't have
access to this data and even the
companies within themselves don't have
access to each other's companies so I'm
gonna just skip the numerical result but
I'm going to show you a little
Mechanical Turk implementation of this
we did and runs we did with humans to
show that it's funny because you can
actually show that this is the way
people learn so this is the online game
we created so this is a Mechanical Turk
interface now in which players log in to
their Mechanical Turk account and then
they play a game in which they're asked
to route people from certain origins to
certain destinations so you could view
this as a you know the Google router guy
whoever is in charge of routing in a
sense is gonna play against the Apple
router guy and it's gonna play against
the Waze rider guy and so on so
everybody is competing for resources on
that network and every can adjust the
way they allocate their flow which again
is not what companies are doing for most
of them today companies today are just
giving you a shortest path they're not
solving a dynamic traffic assignment yet
all of them without having all the
information of the other companies but
let's assume they did then this is what
they would do they would say ok well I'm
the guy running the Google app today so
if I want to go from here to here I'm
gonna have I don't know 10% go this path
and then another 10% go that path and
the third go that path and so on so you
can play with the proportions you don't
know what the others are playing
obviously but you know that they're
playing the same game as you are and
then the question is well this is
exactly the model we had before so can
we show at least that if we have real
people playing that game it does
converge to a Nash equilibrium in
practice which you can assess because
once you have converge to a Nash
equilibrium in a sense you can see the
travel time is equalized on all the
paths and there is no incentive to
deviate and so that's that's what the
game does so people can look at every
iteration of the game at
network they can allocate the flows
according to the slider rules and then
it can get they can see how well they're
doing on each of the paths so for
example here you have a lot of flow on
the blue path and most of the flow is
the rest of the flow is equalized on the
other path and then you can see for
every path which path is better in which
passes worse and so so that's the way
you build it so people play together
they don't have access to each other's
information and what's interesting about
this is that you I don't know how people
learn some people are maybe very fast
learners and some people are very slow
learners so you don't know the it as a
priority if you are trying to fit a
model to understand how people learn but
the process of understanding the
learning rate of people is actually a
complex program so in the learning rate
so finding your if I have access to all
your data and all the choices you made
finding your learning rate according to
that model is a convex program and so
that's one of the things we were very
excited when we found out about this
because now we look at the data and we
can try to understand people's learning
rates and when you look at people's
learning behavior I mean it's
interesting initially people start to
play and they do very poorly on one link
and they do very well on another link so
there's a lot of exploration and after a
while there is some convergence and you
can see how they learned and one of the
things so when that thing stabilizes and
then one thing we're doing now is
understand well if you can see how they
learn you can probably also forecast
what they will do in the future yeah
since since you're playing this refusing
oh well you don't defend zon who you are
if you're the government you don't want
to well if you are one of these comp
well if you're the government you don't
want to play - you want to play social
equilibrium you want to pay social
optimum obviously if your company why
would you want to play nash reelected oh
if you want to relax it yeah well yeah
yeah i don't know about the elections
but i'm yeah but uh okay i don't know
it's it's a hard statement that people
that companies would want or not want to
play nash but today if they don't give
you something which is selfishly optimal
for you they will lose you as a customer
because you'll find the other app that
gives you something better for you so in
a sense it's not that they're solving a
nash problem but they are providing a
solution which should be as close as
possible from nash if they want to keep
you as a customer if i give you if I
give you a ten minutes longer route to
Palo Alto just for it to benefit to
society because you've got to decongest
101 then you're going to use you know
gonna use my app anymore because I don't
help you I help society but I don't help
you personally there's a Nash that
basically forces everybody else to do
very poorly by threatening to do very
bad things to them is that sounds very
much like North Korea
you you you could try and I mean these
companies could try and play these games
if you if you restrict your solution
concept yeah but the thing is it okay
it's an interesting thing we don't
restrict our we don't restrict our
solution space to Nash we make
assumption on what the companies are
doing and we show that if the companies
were doing this then at best they're
converging to Nash now I think a logical
step from what you're saying would be
okay let's try to do other things that
could be doing and could we converge to
something better than Nash and that is
that is a true question actually there
are a lot of interesting work some of
them done by Johansen in Sweden where if
you prove people's cost function that
goes back to Balor G's talk then you can
converse to social optimum so say you
and care 10 minutes extra but you get $2
your cost function is now weight of time
plus money I can get you to convert to
something different and so that's
probably one way to think about these
things if you want to do if you want
people to not behave selfishly that's
where you have to incorporate remarks or
like you're saying that maybe the North
Korea weight penalties you know
it's and by the way it's not a repeated
and and by the way and it's not a
one-shot game last thing is the system
is never at equilibrium because the
results just show that in the first
assumption on average it converges to
Nash the second one it converges almost
surely to Nash and in the third one it
converges with a given rate to Nash but
the system is never at equilibrium
that's very important okay in in my mind
I think about okay so
exactly but that's the that's the
equilibrium state exactly so that's the
point it's a repeated you could view
that it's a let's put let's not use the
word game for the iteration process like
it's a sequential decision making
problem okay you know game and okay this
is maybe the disconnect I think you just
you pointed it exactly and it actually
converges to the to a Nash equilibrium
of the one-shot exactly that's that's
the probably the disconnect so because
there's nothing in the sequential
decision-making process about a game
it's just every day you're doing an
optimization based on some criteria the
app is good to you every day and see
which one gives you the best that's what
hot wire does for airlines I mean I
don't know I mean it depends it depends
I know this is a very interesting
philosophical question right I mean
think about when you're buying an
airline ticket if there's an app that
gives you the best price on average
would you still want to try I mean like
that's why I write so I mean it's a
philosophical debate but yeah yeah okay
yeah so okay so that's another very good
point and absolutely true and people
have infinite confidence in the app
because at the end
Waze is giving you a travel time or
whatever application yeah but absolutely
yeah fair enough so the analogy in that
sense is is poor because one is like
perfect information okay once you click
you paid that much as opposed to you
think you're going to take thirty five
minutes to go to work but oh it turns
out oops you took 45 yeah
yeah so okay and so this is very yeah
and so that is another thing which is
interesting so most of the planning
agencies today when they compute the
assignment problem they solve the
one-shot game the Nash equilibrium not
even the dynamic traffic assignment and
in a sense that's what they use for
their forecasts so there's a lot of work
in the planning in terms of defining
what is a solution of the assignment
problem and yeah I don't think there is
closure even the new practitioners
community there for many reasons when
one of them being that the origin
destination data demand data is not very
good I see that we're nearing the end so
I don't want to get mad at me if I go
overtime I'm gonna finish it in two or
three minutes but I'd love to have more
conversation is a good coffee
conversation so let me let me finish
quickly what's really amazing and really
funny about this is that when you look
at the news and I don't want to pinpoint
any particular company what you see in
the news I'm just not going to read them
I'm just gonna show them you can make
your own opinion and by the way this is
also true on the East Coast with other
institutions so basically people assume
this is perfect we just have this
conversation people assume that because
what you're doing is because what you're
doing is best for you shortest path is
good for society which is basically
confusing like the front page of the
newspapers confuses a Nash equilibrium
and a social optimum solution which we
all know is absolutely not true
but what's what's funny about it is that
well then people get upset so if you
live in Southern California you know and
if you take an uber to LAX or Burbank
you will see that you go through
neighborhoods you've never gone before
why because most of the ubirr drivers
use a specific app and it will take you
from that neighborhood and so what is
that that is actually a displacement of
something that must be worse than a Nash
equilibrium into something that might be
closer to a Nash equilibrium so it's
interesting because you have actually
three levels in an ideal paradisiac way
you have social optimum okay probably
never exist
in reality you have something which is
really bad and actually steering it
towards a Nash equilibria might actually
make it better why because people who
didn't even know about these options
will do something which is not even as
good so think about the early ages
the mobile internet would you really
take the app that goes through the
neighborhood that you didn't really know
about and you think is dangerous I mean
it took a lot of time for people to get
to this but we're getting there now and
so that's where you can see this
steering from this really bad
equilibrium to something which is closer
to a Nash equilibrium and that gets
people really upset because you know
they see more traffic in their
neighborhoods
so it's interesting because then people
start to want to sabotage this and the
way you do it is you pay grandma to a
grandpa to walk on the street with the
app pretending their car stuck in
traffic people have done that in the
past okay and if your city official you
built street signs and bump you you
basically build a stop sign to decrease
the travel time in your neighborhood so
people avoid it so that's the way people
defend themselves against it I mean the
people get involved in it you know we've
talked to many cities the the only way
they can make people get out of their
neighborhoods is make their traffic
worse and so you see a lot if you see a
lot of street new stop signs and new
street bumps that's mostly because the
locals have figured out that they don't
want a Nash equilibrium okay and they
don't want people to steer traffic
towards a Nash equilibrium because it's
bad for their neighborhood and so that's
the type of work that we do now in the
connected corridors program in in
Southern California is trying to
understand you know say if overnight 15%
start to use Waze or any other app what
does it do to your local neighborhood
and so typically you know you get to
start where you have a lot of people on
the freeway - well cool now you have
less people on the freeway and initial
yeah nobody in your city and now well it
looks like Bangalore and I maybe not as
bad and and so what happened in the
process of doing this is the more people
use it the more you know the travel
times is better it decreases on the
freeway and okay first they go through
that first route that difficult it is
okay that goes to our first round okay
and then that first part gets really
congested so then the app figures it out
then they start to go through the second
route okay it contrasts the second
street so that's the second thing here
until the equalize and that's a Nash
equilibria so this is what's happening
today and of course the the speed at
which this happens is slow people are
taking a long time to learn to adopt to
start using the apps over and over but
this is what's happening that's a real
problem in
urban planning today and so that's the
type of models that that we're working
on and that goes back to you know what
is the proper definition of equilibrium
and in truth is neither social optimum
nor ash non ash its right now is
something different and I'm gonna stop
now because I think we're over time but
basically maybe my last slide so
historically I think what was amazing
about the last decade is that the last
decade with the mobile internet give
availability of information everybody
now has access to routing information
anybody can figure out within one app
click the shortest path that's what
happened over the last decade and so now
in the past travel time optimal control
era where you know you know what's you
know what's best for you and you
potentially know what's best for society
how do we achieve it in a way that is
optimum so that goes back to biology
stalk is like what are the right
incentives that enable people to do the
right thing how can you how can we make
you want to waste ten minutes of your
time for a reward so that it's overall
better for society which is really what
Bella G's work is so I'm gonna stop now
but thank you for the good questions and
I think we can talk more of our coffee
thank you